it's like if Justin Bieber was also an
Olympic Athlete you know I suppose so
yeah I find that there are similarities
though one taught me the the what you
put in is what you get out the work
equals Improvement sometimes you sort of
just have to jump off the deep end and
then find your feet once you're out
there you're never gonna feel already my
first race back was terrible failure
isn't failure really failure or just
it's information
thank you for inviting me into your
beautiful home thank you yeah it's good
to have you here yeah it's cool uh I've
been following you for a while now and
it's been quite a uh a kind of dramatic
unfoldment in so many unique and
interesting ways that I want to explore
with you today so you you're of that
generation where you start as a very
young kid sharing
your songs online right like originally
on MySpace yeah that's how it all
started and then eventually YouTube I
was literally discovered on MySpace
which is crazy to think about now
um
and and YouTube but but I was posting
like songs I was writing when I was 11
12 like on Myspace music and that was
that was where I was initially contacted
by a producer in the states
um
how old were you uh 12 when I was first
like contacted I didn't go end up going
over there till I was sort of
13 and then
um 14 when we moved uh but originally
I was 12 when I started to see some kind
of get viewership and all that stuff and
I just dead started for fun because I
saw people were doing it that's what
kids were doing it I saw
um
people just posting these Handycam
videos of them playing and seeing uh
seeing them playing guitar
um and this is sort of all well
understood now I mean that's what
happened with Justin yeah
right like yeah so there's a now there's
sort of a tradition and a track now it's
kind of like the only way you
you
are are saying I suppose
[Music]
um
and it's it's a little bit more
um democratized now in the way that you
sort of anyone can just sort of jump on
and start building a fan base and
everything um cool which is cool but
I was
sort of at the beginning of that YouTube
generation of kids that went on with the
guitar and got discovered
um
and that was the first one out of
Australia as well
um
from my knowledge right
um but uh
and and that's sort of I was flying over
to the states and asked to sort of cut
cutting demos and took some meetings
with some labels who wanted to meet in
in New York and I'd never been out of
the country before so it was all very
new to me and came home for I was
telling you this the other day uh like
came home for six months didn't really
hear anything went back to swimming
training
um and then basically got a deal off on
the table it was sort of
contingent on moving to La
um
and fortunately enough my parents were
willing to take me over there for I
think what they thought would only be a
little while
um but turn that turned out to be us
relocating there full time once the
train started moving you have two
siblings two younger siblings and they
came over with me my I was only 14 so my
sister would have been 13. my brother
was
seven
um
and uh so to have them do that with me
and support me through that was pretty
wild like I don't I don't think every
family would would right would do that I
saw my parents definitely weren't
weren't super well off or anything like
they they helped us get over there and
then for a while it was sort of like up
to me to
sort of make it happen right so on some
level you're supporting a family yeah
yeah and your your mom was your manager
right no no she wasn't but um they they
were involved in the beginning just just
making sure I was safe and all that like
I wasn't getting you know eaten alive
yeah well you're not I mean 13 you're
not going over alone no I'm not a
um and but you know we we were all super
new to the business like we didn't know
anything and and as Australians too you
kind of like
you feel like everyone's telling the
truth all the time like
you're in these meetings they're all
telling you everything you want to hear
and you realize like it's all
yeah yeah and you realize a couple years
later oh that was not true or you know
yeah um so you wake up to that stuff
pretty quickly your parents seem like
really good parents
yeah you know your your brother is like
a concert pianist yeah yeah
um and he's like is he writing uh he's
like writing a musical or he's yeah he's
a very good classical pianist he is he's
now he's just moved to London he bought
himself a one-way ticket to London it's
like saved up for this ticket and for a
few months rent and
um
said see you later to us basically um
wanted to go and and work in theater
over there and he's just got himself uh
he'd done a lot of sort of local
um production and lighting and Stage
management and stuff like that
um and he's now working on an opera wow
on West End like this Italian opera and
he's like gets to get dressed up and go
out and move props around and do all
this and he landed himself that job
within like eight weeks of being there
um so he was like me a lot in that way
where he's just like would go out and
just
make make stuff happen for himself your
sister is like a host and does a bunch
of stuff right yeah yeah a lot of sort
of TV right and Fashion Beauty that kind
of thing yeah but it's interesting that
social media you are kind of in the
creative arts your parents were both
athletes swimmers yeah like they weren't
like making albums and writing operas
he's
um yeah my parents my dad my dad writes
music and he he sings and plays guitar
and that's sort of what
that's where I got it from I think
that's where we my mom my mom is not not
highly musical
um but uh
they never they never pursued any
anything of the sort in their lives so I
think seeing us all take those passes
interesting for them yeah that is that's
wild and so what do you when you reflect
back on how you were raised the way in
which your parents raised you like what
it it feels like they must be very
encouraging to appreciate their dreams
and whatever form that that comes in
like how did they kind of support you on
the day-to-day yeah well when they first
when they when we talk about us first
moving over there they said
they said that if and if we came back in
a few months they said worst case we
taught you to follow your dreams and
your gut because I was so passionate
about wanting to go over there and
pursue this and take the opportunity I
was given in music so they said worst
case we've we've taught you that you can
do that you know and I'm just glad they
they had an open enough Minds to to
allow that to happen
um and it was good too because they
never they never were like pushy even in
swimming like they never
they're encouraging but never never
pushy which is which was good but when
you wanted to get back in the pool your
mom was not so yeah back in the pool mum
was I was trying to stop me from prevent
me from doing it you don't want to do
that look what you're doing you want to
come like she knows yeah yeah yeah she
she knew so she
she was shocked um but I think when she
just saw the way I talked about it she
was like well I can't stop you I haven't
stopped you before right yeah so there
you've done so many things as an
Entertainer we're never going to be able
to talk about all of that but
um you did you must have been 15 like
when you were when you went on tour with
Bieber
yeah you were like the opening act 15
yeah when I started yeah I mean that had
to be bananas yes it was only sort of
uh
uh a year or two into being being over
there right
um
just signed with scooter Brawn his
manager
um the swifties are gonna be very upset
let's see yeah
um
and he
and so I started started working with
him and his team and and got to know
Justin a little bit and you know who
obviously at that time was sort of the
biggest young act in the world
um and just got put on put on tour with
him for I just just released my first
album through through
um through Atlantic through Warner and
and pretty much jump straight on tourism
for how did that even that came together
because of scooter yeah yeah yeah yeah
and just just um
it made sense you know being the I was a
couple years younger than him but but
coming up as sort of another he's the
next young artist yeah
um and then so him and I sort of
developed a relationship beyond that
um ended up working on sort of playing
music together and just you know develop
sort of a loose friendship for for a
while
um
and uh
yeah it was wild to be sort of thrust
into that at that at that point yeah
going from six months prior I was
playing like shopping centers and then
like I'm doing doing um Arenas around
the country and we ended up joining him
on his Australia leg and and some of
Europe and so that was wild right yeah
how long were you with Scooter Braun
about
three years three four years and
that was when I
I pretty much
made changes to my whole
situation at the same time from
management to record label pretty much
asked
to be let out of everything I was
involved in and once you were with
scooter or after leaving him after yeah
right yeah so this is when I when I went
oh I was still with him probably for for
the first uh went independent label wise
for for about 12 months and then ended
up ended up um
changing management situation as well
after that just because I felt like I
wanted a whole new sort of
approach it was it was looking back on
it now I think it was a bit drastic of
me but but at that age it's sort of like
I almost felt sort of Trapped in it's
it's a weird thing because you you like
you almost feel trapped in what you've
built for yourself right so Scooter
Braun you know notorious hitmaker I'm
sure he's
saying to you look I know exactly the
building blocks here and I can get you
to be the next Justin do these things
live your life this way here's how we're
going to do it it's all very strategic
So when you say prison meaning the
confines of like what that path was
going to look like for you I think so as
an artist yeah well and scooter though
was to
um to his credit he was supportive of
like the musical Direction I wanted to
take I don't think he was he wasn't
necessarily pushing me into
yeah yeah he was like I want you to you
know you should play your guitar you
should you know he he was sort of he was
if anything pushing me in a different
direction say to Justin who was the you
know pop star doing choreography and
doing all that stuff but it was more
just within me that I sort of say I want
a different I don't want to be in this
circle
oh you know and it was it was more it
was more an act of just Rebellion on on
my part because I wasn't happy with
or or I didn't I felt like a different
person to what everybody thought I I was
just just just me music-wise because I
sort of started to grow up really fast
and had a lot of personal changes and
you know at 15 you
at at
18 19 you you start to like a lot of
different things than you did when you
were 15 16 and that happens pretty
quickly
um or at least it did for me like and
discovered all this other music and
realized I wanted to
uh sort of make these shifts from from
where I was
um and now I've it was almost like this
pendulum swing one way and then it goes
all the way the other way and then now
I'm sort of back in the middle right and
a little less like you were on Atlantic
right you're assigned to Atlantic so
walk me through the decision to not
continue to have a relationship with a
big record label and to go independent
because I think it speaks to a larger
issue around
um
rights of entertainers and how you think
about ownership in your own career like
now you own your Masters right like is
that true like yeah you have your my
control over your library now which is
very unusual my my later catalog yeah
yeah my my stuff sort of since not not
my Warner catalog but yeah what I've
done since yeah I have I have sort of
control over what I'd like to do that
whether I you know keep growing it and
you sort of you know get your own
publishing deal based on you know the
Masters you own I made a sort of
co-owned Masters say with my own masters
say with you know certain collaborators
that I've worked on them that the um
the albums with but yeah it's not owned
by a a major corporation or anything and
so that that decision was about and you
know the creative aspect aside like just
from a business point of view and the
way that the music business operates how
does that how to like what how did that
come about at that point I wasn't
thinking about the the business aspect
as much
um I wasn't really as as
business-minded or as financially aware
as I am now
um
sort of having to almost being forced to
to especially once you do go out on your
own you're sort of forced to learn how
how that all works and um yeah I uh yeah
I get a sense are you feeling like maybe
you know like don't hold me out to uh be
the guy who made like the best decision
right yeah maybe I would have done it a
little bit differently yeah I can't say
I would have done it all the same way
then but but I think long term it will
it will be to your benefits yeah yeah
right but I also got to zoom out a
little bit and and go and think about
drop a Grenade on your career
unnecessarily right right
sometimes I think about that yeah but
but
yeah as you said before
when you look back in the review it's
like it all makes sense kind of right
the way it all unfolds and I think I
just got to keep zooming out knowing
thinking about
where I'm going in the future as a
musician it's all going to be to my
benefit eventually to have have
ownership of a larger portion of my
catalog and
um
yeah at that point I wasn't really
thinking about the business side of it I
was more I was I was concerned with the
way I was viewed and creatively and as a
person and all this stuff
um
but I think now I feel much more
comfortable within that Within Myself
and
um
yeah I
and also I haven't I haven't given it a
whole lot of thought lately because I
haven't really
I've just been so wrapped up in
something else
um but the thing is it's always there
like swimming can't always be there no
because there's a biological clock
ticking yeah but there isn't as a
creative as a performer like you know
that when you're ready you'll be able to
devote your energy to that you know the
other thing is like you started acting
you did Broadway you did a bunch of TV
stuff um so when you see uh
like I don't know like when you see
Timothy Charlemagne and doomed you think
like hey man if I had like not taken
this detour maybe that's me like do you
Harbor those sorts of thoughts at all or
you're just like I'm cool man I'm like
the swing the swimming Day Tour yeah or
yeah you just are you grounded and just
that convicted in what you're doing
right now that that doesn't those kinds
of thoughts are not part of I have I
have moments yeah I have moments
that guy's doing that yeah
um I could have done that better than
that
I have I don't know about better than
him but yeah
um uh I have moments for sure they're
they're short they're fleeting moments
but but they're there and sometimes you
go but I think no matter what decision
you make you're gonna you're gonna
wonder what the other one would have
been like
um but I also know that I have time yeah
and that's that's that's what gives me
Comfort is that all right I've got time
to to you're doing this thing go back
into Jamie Foster went to call it you
know Yale or Natalie part you know it's
like this is your version of that yeah
yeah exactly and I know that I know that
say even if I stop swimming next year
like I'll be 27 and I can I can you know
look at
or or plan on whatever it is I want to
sort of stop pursuing from there now
it's it's going to be I think
it'll just be music I I that's sort of
my primary interest in uh post swimming
life is is is being a musician and
touring and making records and stuff and
that's that's not going anywhere yeah
and I should say and I said this to you
at breakfast the other day like I have a
special place in my heart for you know
high performance in general we can all
learn from people who are excelling uh
in their in their respective disciplines
but there's something really cool and
unique about people who find a way to
um achieve Legend status in a
multiplicity of of kind of Specialties
yeah in my generation like I'm your
parents age I grew up in a time where
you kind of had to pick like are you
going to be an artist are you going to
be a creative type or are you going to
be an athlete and like never the twain
do those two things meet and I was
talking to my daughter who's 19 the
other day and sharing with her about
Leslie and how I was going to talk to
you yeah she's an artist and she's a
painter and sculptor and she's like Dad
it's not like that anymore yeah is that
true do you think there's a
permissiveness around
that in a way that might have been
different when I was growing up I think
that boundaries have sort of slowly been
disintegrating in a way like it and I
think that's due to people doing
things that I think otherwise or
previously weren't considered possible
or you know
um
too much to do or excel at in one
Lifetime right like I think um and
that's sort of
when I was jumping back in the pool was
sort of one of my
not motivations but but something that
that I found interesting that I could
possibly inspire people to sort of let
go of those
mental constructs of like if I'm this I
have to only be this and only this
forever
um
and
it was fun challenging that in my own
life and then also
it has been fun challenging that in my
own life you know about just just seeing
what's possible that's what all this has
sort of been about for me and just
seeing what's possible and
and then also hopefully it
um inspiring other people or at least
challenging their ideas about what's
possible too you know were you very
conscious of that when you made that
decision or is that something that kind
of percolated up in the process of of
you getting back in the pool and
exploring that it I think it happened in
the process I think that me getting back
in the pool was just that I felt like I
couldn't stay away from it anymore and
had this Burning desire to do it
um and just like the whole thing was
about
the what ifs were going to be too much
for me in the future to to not have a
crack and and and and to live with those
regrets or or what ifs of not having
tried
um
and then
and then when I started and things sort
of started to to develop and and
progress I realized I sort of became a
little bit more self-aware about what I
was actually doing and when I started to
realize that I didn't have anyone to
look to to or a blueprint to follow
about how it was how it should be done
realizing that no one in swimming had
really ever done that before
um
you know people had sort of won or made
the Olympics and then like
won again 10 years later after having a
bunch of time out like you know an
Anthony Irvin or right these guys that
have these super interesting stories but
they kind of stopped at a super high
level or at the top and then kind of
like took a bunch of years off and then
came back got back to the top
um whereas I don't think anyone sort of
stopped
young at like an age group level and
then decides 10 years later to to try
and uh make that Elite level yeah
there's there's no blueprint there's no
precedent nobody has ever done that
before uh I remember when Pablo Morales
jumped back into the pool like he's my
mate he's my buddy I went to law school
with him uh we swam together at Stanford
he was two years older than me
um he's an OG man he's watching him with
no cap and goggles like I know no
goggles old school almost like Mark
Spitz you know style winningest uh nc2a
swimmer ever uh was sort of anointed to
be this extraordinary Olympic champion
and I think he kind of over trained um
that was at 88 was it Seoul where he he
didn't shockingly he didn't make the
team right you know going into that
Olympic trials he was favored to just
you know take everything yeah and hung
it up went to law school we finished law
school together we study for the bar
together and then he got up he got back
into the pool and then did what he did
at the following Olympics and shocked
everyone and that was at the time like
super radical and thinking back like how
old was he he wasn't that old it would
have only been what early 20s still yeah
I think maybe maybe mid-20
nine yeah something like that yeah
um which was was old then super awesome
super awesome because there was no money
in the sport at that time and so when
you finish college when you were 21 that
was it yeah nobody progressed beyond
that now it's very different and to your
point yes Anthony Irvin there's a few
others
um at the peak of their powers took a
break or stepped down and then made a
comeback but you
stopped at 13. yeah and you were very
successful as a 13 year old
but it was unclear how far that was
gonna go yeah it wasn't like you were on
a Michael Phelps track like you were
winning state championships and you were
probably like top in your age group yeah
like yeah and I suppose this is a lot of
you know countless assume is that a good
young and then you never hear of them
again right that may be good until
they're 16 and then disappear or or
whatever I mean I was
um yeah like I was winning sort of
national
age group the titles there for a few
years in a rows particularly and and
butterfly and freestyle events and
um
and then but but that you know that and
obviously that's an indicator of I
suppose you know some some level of
talent or feel for the water or whatever
you want to call it but you know it's
not necessarily a guarantee you know
you're going to grow up to you know make
your national team or you know go and
compete at that level so
um I suppose coming back to it like I
it's it's funny thinking back now to
kind of like the the the blind
confidence that I had coming back into
it when not really realizing I think
that the mountain I was you know under
attacking trying to climb
um
a lot of people you know sort of met
with a lot of are you sure you know even
from my own mom and who who swam for
Australia and sort of understood like
both your parents What it Took yeah
and I think she was sort of like
you know you've got this you've built
this life for yourself in the last 10
years you sure you just want to like put
that all aside to go and stare at the
black line for
for you know hours a day and put
yourself through all that like it's it's
grueling and
um
I I didn't really have any reservations
about it just I just knew it was what I
wanted to do
and I think it's important to point out
for people that are watching or
listening who don't have familiarity
with the sport of swimming swimming is a
sport that is just all about the grind
and
um
it's very unusual for a swimmer to even
take a couple months off yeah to take a
year off are you kidding me like it's
not something that people come back from
when you do that
um and it's also a sport where you spend
just years and years and years
developing those years between 13 and
and 20 whatever right
um but nobody has really popped in I
missed all those foundations what's
interesting about that is yeah so you
didn't have any of that you were still
13 like usually that's right double
workouts and all that kind of stuff
starts around 14 like that's when it
starts to get hard and so you skip that
part
but you were able to pop in it so it was
like 22 23 yeah when you when you got
back in the water 20 22 I was starting
to um pop in every now I'm in the USC
like that's that's I think when you were
talking about Connor Dave Salo Dave with
Dave Salo but again it was very much it
wasn't
it wasn't I hadn't decided to come back
yet I was sort of like I like to swim
you know I'll just jump on the side here
and you know see how it feels and I
hadn't swung at that point and probably
I'd probably swim more than a couple
hundred meters in like nine years or
something eight years
um and so I started to do that then with
them you know when I was in town and I
was still traveling a fair bit for work
and then uh covert happened and
I no touring no touring no nothing
um had already had already been
simmering on this idea for quite a while
probably probably since Rio to be honest
because I went down to Rio and watched
friends of mine that I grew up competing
with competing in the Olympics and
succeeding and doing all this and it
kind of I saw my old coach down there
and
we had like this small little chat about
it about the idea of it that just sort
of sat with me and sparked something
that
simmered for for years until I couldn't
tag it anymore and had to
start to right change my life it's not
even like unfinished business it's like
business you haven't even begun yeah
yeah didn't you also
perform for the queen at Buckingham
Palace at the Commonwealth Games yeah
yeah the most recent Commonwealth Games
right it was for be there and see all
the athletes and there was something
about that as well yeah it was the 2018
Commonwealth Games
um torch lighting like the relay
um and the 2018 games were on the Gold
Coast here where we are which is where I
grew up and I think because of that they
being from the Gold Coast they had me go
over and perform and
sung like I still call Australia home
and did all that in the grounds of the
Buckingham Palace and got to meet the
queen and and do all that and I think
and then and then four years later I was
competing in the next one as a swimmer
and at that time in 2018 was yeah hadn't
hadn't even really considered the idea
of of swimming
um or or really jumping back into it so
it's kind of wild when I was getting up
on the blocks four years later right
um having known four years ago I was
doing what I was doing yeah that's so
weird but when you're performing there
as a singer-songwriter thinking yeah but
I'm an athlete too like nobody's seeing
me as an athlete yeah and no one knows
yeah yeah yeah yeah
no one knows that I can do this and that
yeah and that that was I think that was
a little bit part of it too it was
almost like a thirst to prove myself
knowing that it's almost like you'd
you can say you can do all this and that
as as much as you want you can say oh
yeah I could have been this or I could
you know people people do that all the
time but I I really wanted to
I think prove to myself and to others
that I I
just wanted to see yeah that I was real
about it because I think people I knew
people were kind of like yeah but right
well even Dave Salo didn't he say like
yeah he told didn't you tell Bret Hawk
like yeah this isn't going to work out
yeah yeah Dave Shayla told him
um David mosh told him that which
um yeah these guys are like for people
who don't know like these are the legend
coaches in the sport at least in the
states and David sort of since David
Moss sort of has since had since said or
at least even a couple months after that
he sort of said no you you this is the
second time in my life I've been proved
wrong or that my my judgment wasn't
correct or and I don't think it's a he
thought that I'm not sure it's like he
said it was way back
um but he's but he said um I think it
was maybe about a swimmer that he didn't
think would succeed in nc2as or
something it ended up being quite good
and
um
maybe
Brett took me down this was still very
early I'd only been swimming for a
couple months took me down to do some
sort of technical stuff with David Marsh
down in San Diego and
I think um it was more that
David I think had just said to Brett um
are you sure this you know I think he
should just stick to what he's doing
like is he
you know Tunis had too much time out
This ship's kind of sailed you know yeah
it would it's gonna take
it it's going to be possible to get to
you know where I guess this kid wants to
go right and In fairness the first time
you jumped into a meet you swam like a
5100 yard fly right yeah that was and
that was like before I trained or
anything it was sort of like when I was
doing those little one-off sessions at
USC and they sort of said well there's
this little meet Invitational
um coming up and I I at that time would
say yeah I'll get in and have a go and I
was I was so unfit yeah and uh you know
swam horribly like yeah 51 I mean 51
would be you know good at a master's
meet but yeah anywhere yeah
to a 23 year old and um
and so that was that was months prior to
to covet and all that when I it was sort
of like the first time I'd raised it on
anything of the sort in a long time
um
it's almost just a bit of fun at that
point but uh I remember sitting sitting
with Dave Salo actually going I want to
go 51 and 100
long course meter fly and he kind of
just you know I could see him smoking
going yeah you understand what that
takes you know and um
last year I did it so right yeah
it's just like wild to to think back
actually sitting here with you you don't
I don't often do that retrospect
it's not reflection reflect back on that
I mean I think you know it it all
happened pretty quickly also not without
its lumps
um and 51 long course it's like 51-0
right or 51-17 yeah I mean that's but
legit dude like and what's
exciting is that to the earlier point of
you
in this unprecedented way jumping into
the pool at a later age you and having
missed that decade of the grind yeah
most of the swimmers at the highest
level who all of them endured that
decade of grind are now trying to hang
on like and stay enthusiastic about
something that's just so hard to
maintain long term because you have to
live this monastic lifestyle and you
know when you're 24 whatever you pretty
much know you're going to have some
gains you put in the extra effort
there's always Improvement to be had but
you're not really going to get a massive
performance leap like you pretty much
know kind of where you are in the
pecking order but for you there are no
rules like yeah the potential is you
know the sky's the limit in terms of
like what you're now capable of and I
know you're coming off a huge block this
past year and you're about to you know
compete and you're at the beginning of
your taper yeah and that's got to be way
more exciting for somebody like you than
even for Emma your girlfriend who's been
in it for a long time like the pretty
good idea of probably where they're
going to end up and and for you I think
that's just totally Unwritten it's it's
one of the mental advantages that I
think I have
um
is it there's so much unknown still for
me in the sport and that sort of just
keeps me going because I go I just don't
know where where I can get to maybe have
some of my fastest swims I don't know if
I have you know that is what it is right
like you you fulfilled that commitment
that you made but I made that to myself
and and I I
it's you know wanted to represent
Australia and I wanted to get that you
know we we call it um our dolphin number
which is basically what the Australian
swim team are called the Dolphins and
everyone that gets selected to compete
gets a number and so
there's been I'm Number 838 so there's
been 838 swimmers compete for Australia
in the history of I think it's been
since
uh 1901 or something like that
um
and so that's something really sort of
monumental and special for an Australian
swimmer to get their number and I got
that last year when I went to the com
games and my mom had one and so just
sort of be able to have that together
and
um that's something that having those
little things is sort of
makes me feel like no matter what
happens in the future like I've sort of
have these things to show for what I
what I've sort of committed to and what
I wanted to prove to myself which in a
way I've done part of that already I
still feel like I have a lot more I want
to do but I'm really glad that I've been
able to
sort of uncover that or at least at
least prove to myself that I could kind
of do what I suspected I might be able
to with the right with the right work
and stimulus and stuff I want to dig a
little bit more into that in a minute
but
here we are uh spring 2023.
um what's the big meet I mean by the
time this goes up that meat will have
passed yeah talk about like kind of
where you're at now and how you're
thinking about next year in Paris in the
Olympics yeah well I guess I'm almost
three years into
four-year Journey that I that I embarked
on I I I started having
only the plan to swim for four years
um anything beyond that is still still
unknown to me I don't know what what I
want to do or how I feel after Paris
either the you know the trials or the
Olympics or whatever like kind of
depends on how I go and and how I feel
then
um
yeah but the whole plan is to be ready
for 2024 so everything I'm doing is sort
of with that Insight uh there's a our
trials coming up in a few weeks for the
world championships this year
um
so that's sort of the next major team to
qualify for in the between now and and
in the Olympics
um so do my best to get on that one
and uh everything else is kind of
leading up to
about right 13 14 months so this is
still like a build a year next year is
the real year where you know the rubber
meets the road pretty much and the super
grind starts uh but you've already made
a commonwealth team you defied
expectations you got so for people that
don't know you in order to go to the
Olympics you have to get first or second
at your trials yeah yeah um and third
place and under our
um qualifying time so if you're a second
and you you know another time you're
probably probably not going right yeah
that's not going to be a factor though
um but but often for at least for the
The Strokes the 100 meter Strokes they
they usually want to take two per event
for the the relays and and this is a lot
of relays now with the mixed the mixed
uh men's and women's relays and all that
so they want I think they want to you
know they'll want two men for 100 fly
200 400 breasts Etc right so even if you
get
third there's still a chance you could
end up on a relay or on the Internet no
you're out yeah okay even if you're on
even if you're under the qualifying time
which the Australian qualifying times uh
um significantly faster than the fina a
cut times the Australian qualifying
times they they um
figure out based on what made last
year's final at Worlds so like the
eighth eighth time so basically they're
picking
they're only taking you if they feel
like you can make sort of the
international final or whatever which is
you know it's probably aside from I
suppose the USA it's probably the
hardest swimming team in the world to to
get on yeah that's a debate yeah the
Aussie versus Aussie vs us that'll
always legendary uh yeah survivals um so
you got so you're kind of sitting in
this third place position you got third
at your trials last year you almost went
to the World Championships though
because there was something about
somebody who was gonna not participate
in that event but then he changed his
mind yeah the Commonwealth team yeah
where you got the fifth but you're in
the mix I guess is the point that I'm
making but there's no guarantees either
either way there's no I'm sort of on the
precipice of or the cusp of of
qualification for at least from for my
events
um probably sitting sitting right on the
cusp of them so it's there's definitely
no guarantees
and do you feel that uh
that you have a leg up in terms of how
you manage stress and pressure because
of the things that you've done as an
Entertainer where you've put yourself in
kind of high stress situations yeah uh
and and you have like a little bit of
experience uh that that that maybe you
know allows you to handle that stuff
with more calm and Grace probably yeah
I
yeah I tend I tend to find I I
can do
thriving high pressure pressure
situations
um
having
as you said the having done
many different kinds of things that and
been in many different kinds of I
suppose
high pressure situations or at least
doing things with a lot of eyeballs on
you yeah being up on stage in front of a
lot of people being in on TV shows and
all that kind of stuff yeah I found
Broadway coming back into coming back
into the sport like I wasn't
I was a part of me had that that
um that fear and nerve based around just
being new and not having the experience
in the race race experience and
confidence knowing that when I did get
up on the blocks like people would be
watching
um
even at like local meets and stuff when
I first came back I just always felt
like yeah right eyeballs on me and stuff
now it's I think I've been here long
enough where it's a little less
um
I feel like a little less scrutinized
but uh
was definitely prepared for that just
through the life experience that I've
had vice versa do you feel that your
career as a young swimmer when you were
13 and having to be in a high stress
situation even as a young person helped
you when you started getting up on
stages because I feel like I'm here I
gave this speech the other day yeah and
I had to do it in front of a lot of
people and even though it's been many
years since I was a swimmer like it is
it does it felt like finals it felt like
you know you get you're a little nervous
but it's that excitement I know what
this is like I want to perform well Etc
like there's a lot of overlap I think
yeah yeah yeah I I think that oh it
taught me a ton as as a kid even just
yeah carrying that into my life as an
artist and a musician Beyond
my swimming as a young kid was
prepared me for well one taught me the
the correlation between sort of the what
you put in is what you get out sort of
mindset the work equals success or work
equal at least equals Improvement that's
different in the creative arts you can't
you can't grind a song out like it's not
like doing a hard set like you got to be
in a place of allowing and almost
surrender right to like let that come in
which is antithetical to the mindset of
the swimmer who's like if I push hard I
know I will have these gains yeah yeah I
find that there's
I find that there are similarities
though at least at least from my
experience
um trying to improve as a guitarist or
trying to improve as a vocalist to say
go on to go on
um to do theater right like to do things
like that
um things where the Reps pay off yeah
like
where you sort of push push push for for
a period of time so that you can
let it sort of happen when it's supposed
to happen so that the the the second
nature thing can happen like right when
you're when you're when you're racing at
your Peak you're not using your brain
yeah exactly cursed it so you can you
can think think think so that you cannot
think when you when you don't have to
and I think that's the same thing for at
least for performing or playing a a song
say something difficult that you've been
wanting to learn
um
I was I
I don't know if I I said this at one
point if someone else did if I heard it
but I liked the idea that slow
a slow growth stage will lead to a quick
burst of Blossom at the time that you
many slow growth stages will lead to a
quick burst of Blossom
um I've found that that's very true for
swimming I think when you get that
breakthrough
um you'll touch the wall look at the
time and you you get that you know when
you have that breakthrough that time
drop you it's like a euphoric feeling
right you know you know the work that
you put in yeah and that's I think
that's what makes it so beautiful is is
what you put in and and and sort of
grinding through that time to get that
to get that feeling that reward yeah
yeah the one thing you got to figure out
though dude you got to figure out how to
go faster at finals I know I know like
that's that's a little bit of a struggle
for you that's uh it's funny you say
that actually you've done your research
you're good at prelims dude but you got
to be ready for that Big Show yeah and
that's something as funny as my coach
tells me all the time and that's
something I'm working on is
I'm good when I'm relaxed like I'll get
up in the Heat and go okay I can at
least at least nationally like I know I
can get up and go eight out of ten and
make the the final
um and often that swim will be faster
than the one where I'm getting in and
just trying to tear it right you know
and it's funny swimming in that way as
that counter-intuitive
where it's more effort doesn't always
mean faster right I mean that's that's a
really important perspective but I I
would feel that you would be somebody
who would understand that better because
I'm sure when you're performing music in
front of a lot of people
it's going to be better when you're
relaxed yeah yeah if you're trying to
force it or you're tensed up
performance right yeah and that's I
think that's just something I'm learning
with experience at least in the pool
realizing that it it is that way
[Music]
um
but uh I think it's going to come with
with more you know I'm getting up having
swam say I don't know how many hundreds
fly I've done in a race environment
maybe 40 or 50. I'm not sure
um getting up against guys they've done
hundreds of them yeah I'm just sort of
trying to get more of that under my belt
so I can but yeah that is something I'm
working on but the mindset has to be
these guys don't know like you're the
question mark yeah you know and that
that's like a superpower yeah yeah you
pretty much know what these other guys
are gonna you know the range that
they're gonna be in but
all bets are off when you get up on the
blocks yeah yeah because it's also new
absolutely and I think that's the way it
was coming into last year like my my
time at least coming into the the trials
last year was
really not not anywhere near like you
dropped from like a 54 to a 51 right in
in about
a year
um was it
yeah in about in about 18 months I think
yeah
yeah that's I mean that's like in 100
meter I mean that's like an astonishing
you know Improvement for that period of
time but I think going into lost your
trials was like 2 52 8 or something was
as quick as I'd been and uh you know I
knew I'd have to go 51a on the team and
when I did that in the heat I kind of
showed myself I was ready to go there
but this year I have to make an uh even
bigger drops uh what was that like
dropping back in moving back here
getting back into swimming with you know
jumping into the pool with an Elite
Squad
of guys and gals did they welcome you
back or was there a lot of sort of
Suspicion like what are you playing at
like come on man I think there was some
of that and some of some of the people
who I'm now friends with sort of you
know said that they just naturally had
those thoughts I think when I first came
back just they didn't know me they
didn't
you know know what really what I was
doing what my plan was
um so I think some people kind of at
least at least a lot of people in the
public are and stuff you know thought it
was like a some kind of publicity start
or something yeah yeah this is for this
is for the gram yeah yeah and I'm like
swimming it's not worth it for the grab
like it takes way too much you know
that's the thing so you can just like
put together in a couple days yeah
um I remember like but I was welcomed I
was yeah I was wrong with 51 so it's
legit but at first I would imagine there
was a little bit of a acclimation period
yeah when I first came back like I I'd
obviously dropped
I'd obviously gotten to a decent level
in a short period of time but it's not
necessarily enough to like have people
say like you belong here you know yeah
yeah yeah this is different than just
yeah uh you know photos of you on
Instagram with your shirt off yeah yeah
and In fairness like when I first got
introduced to you and I was like
checking I was like I don't know man I
don't know about this like when I look
at your social media or like if if
someone is to Google you it's just Rife
with a bunch of Paparazzi you
needed like you know some well-known
women and yeah it's really kind of all
about that and it's easy to project or
have a judgment about who you are or
what's important to you based upon that
um
and then when I met you and had
breakfast with you the other day I was
like oh this is nothing like like this
guy in reality is nothing like
I imagine based upon that kind of public
Persona or image like you're very
grounded you know conscious kind
pretty chilled out dude thanks thank you
now
um so it's not surprising that you would
get yeah you know some of that is it
from your experience that a lot of
people that at least have been through
that Aunt
that way or well because you and I think
both probably know a lot of people who
actually have sort of had been shrouded
in that yeah yeah world or that I mean I
think I'm in a unique position to talk
to you because I live in Los Angeles and
I know a lot of the people that you've
worked with you know I understand that
culture
um but I also have the swimming
background like you know I I can like I
have direct experience with both of
those worlds and I would say that in
general and this is no mystery like
somebody who experiences that level of
Fame and attention at a young age uh
they don't you know that that has a
tendency to really impair your value
system yeah and it's intoxicating and
now that you say that honestly like a
lot of the people that I that I or at
least a few of the people that I do know
or have have been
um introduced to that that had that uh
do have a sort of warped yeah
perspective and I think In fairness from
my and correct me if I'm wrong but you
look like somebody who flirted with that
you know it could have gone the other
way yeah yeah I mean my parents will
tell you you were like I mean you were
living a pretty fast lifestyle yeah
absolutely and and to Eric in late teens
even even early 20s I was
there were moments I was caught up like
I didn't know which way it was going I
think my
and my parents sort of worse nightmares
of like
you know young sort of
pop star kid like going off the rails
was like coming true for them it comes
true for most people in your situation
it's the rare individual that that
avoids fortunately
for every Justice Timberlake there's you
know a hundred other yeah you know
heroin addicts yeah you look at guys
like I mean
Aaron Carter comes to mind
um so it's just
so many horror stories in that sense and
that was
I was just fortunate to to
I I think I owe a lot of it to my family
to my parents you know because I was at
least still close enough to them where I
really cared what they thought when they
when they expressed that they felt like
I was losing touch a little bit they
they'd they'd bring me back to Earth
yeah so so maybe paint like a a picture
of that moment
you're going to clubs you're dating
women that are you know very well known
you're in you have Paparazzi following
you around you're getting there's a lot
of stuff going on man a lot of
Temptation it's Hollywood yeah you just
have access to it to to way more than
you should at that age and way more than
than
other kids this is like you're you're
like 19 right yeah yeah
younger you know 17 18 so to be able to
you know and
um
I was probably 16 when I started going
out that
um so you just you know all of a sudden
that age seeing Dory swinging open it's
um
it can as you say be intoxicating how
did you kind of avoid the the the like
drugs aspect of the whole thing
um I didn't
um and I saw something I talk about much
but like
it's you know definitely present for and
for for years it was something that
is just a part of being there everyone's
doing it you're going out
it's fun for at the beginning right
um and then when it gets when it gets
too much and you see it start to sort of
uh affect your personal life or
affect your career like I was still
actively working and doing all that
stuff the whole time I'm still playing
music Still Doing gigs doing all this
stuff I mean I was changing I definitely
had a lot of creative and musical change
from being sort of a young pop artist to
wanting to be a sort of more of a
singer-songwriter or play different
at least become a musician I was sort of
like I was very conscious of it
throughout that time like wanting to set
myself up as a musician and and you know
I wasn't lost that stuff wasn't lost on
me I sort of never really disregarded my
career or anything like that but you get
caught up for sure
um
and it's a you know what I was sort of
doing then was
and the lifestyle is living then even
five years ago you know as a 21 year old
as a far cry from where I'm at now I'm
getting I'm gonna I'm waking up when I
was going to sleep yeah yeah yeah yeah I
mean it's almost like uh
you've already had a midlife crisis yeah
at at 20 or whatever you know in the
biopic of your life like I'm that was
the mid-life crisis like waking up in
some weird house after a you know yeah a
banger of a party and and thinking man I
I know where this is heading and I have
this other thing almost like returning
to swimming was almost a defense
mechanism to save your life is that an
extreme that maybe I'm I just got
goosebumps because I was about to tell I
was about to say that in a different way
yes like so explain that
um
and
that was the thing swimming was the
thing that
would swimming was like the sobering
thought
within the
Haze of the
the life I was living
um and was the thing that pulled me out
of
even even sometimes like in moments like
when you're out I'm going it's one or
two a.m everyone's still going I have I
I remember that I want to do this thing
in the future so I can't like trash my
body like this anymore I have to like
start I have to start pulling myself
away from these scenarios in this
lifestyle and I remember there were
there were many nights sort of before I
really put my foot down on my on myself
um that that I would have those moments
and
I think if I didn't have swimming or I
didn't have the the
desire to do that again like I wouldn't
have had anything holding me back from
just sinking right you know
just going full force into into that
that lifestyle because there would be
nothing else that I would have had
nothing else I would have known
um so yeah in a way as you say I think
it did
save my life God I don't know what would
have happened or where I would have gone
beyond that
um
it was the only thing that that I think
aside from my family like drew me out of
it yeah and I'm so glad it did because
like now and I'm sure you you can relate
to this obviously
probably not to the sort of
extreme perhaps that that you're where
your journey took you but
now I just am as so much more
consistently happy on a day-to-day basis
you know maybe the higher the highs on
it's higher maybe the low zone is low
but like I would take this over that any
day I think and I think even in the
future going back into music like
I'd be very cautious about
how I did it and and and for what
reasons you know I'd probably want to
stay based here I'd go maybe go go back
and forth to the States but I don't know
if I think I'd probably want to base
myself on Australia and just do things
on my own terms and
and live a healthy a healthy life and
have a healthy approach to being an
artist as opposed to the kind of
destructive artist approach yeah the
Trope the cliche yeah you know what I
mean and and
you know but when you're in it like yeah
like short of swimming
it is so it's got to be so exciting
doors are swinging open you're meeting
all these people you never thought you
would meet you're you know like you just
have this sort of access and and to say
you know what I I did that I don't feel
like myself it's it's one thing for
and like even if a normal person like a
I don't know like a you call them
sparkies here like a Sparky right like
an electrician yeah he was like you know
what like I was good when I was 13 I'm
gonna pop in again or you're somebody
who's just living a normal life with a
normal job and maybe is a little
unfulfilled and thinks you know what I'm
gonna see if I have some more athletic
potential inside of me that would be an
extraordinary story but the level of of
conviction and discipline that would be
required to step away from that super
like yeah the Peaks are so high right
yeah and say I'm not only am I going to
walk away from that at least temporarily
like I'm gonna go do this other thing
that means I'm going to be exhausted all
the time I'm going to be staring at this
black line there's no guarantees of
anything this is certainly not like a
strategic career move to you know to
like make money or you know like it's
there's a level of insanity to the whole
thing yeah yeah yeah absolutely and I'd
even like I wasn't coming back into it
like even financially like I wasn't
really set up coming back into swimming
I had kind of
I had a few like lean years and was was
kind of in a place where
I
it wasn't like sort of like
I'd probably made some bad financial
decisions and had some poor Management
on that side of things and and you know
so it wasn't that wasn't
it wasn't like I was going into it going
I've got all this cash and I'm gonna
right I'm good I'm sure people I'm
believing people would think that's the
case yeah you're you're with this person
and you have this but that was to be
living in a mansion and yeah a private
driver and like yeah but for me like the
reality for me at that in in that moment
just based on the way things had gone
and just I think miseducation young
about about money and
um and just have poor sort of financial
management and things for a few years
like I'd I go I was in a place where I
wasn't sort of like yeah if I go and
swim
I'm for sure support myself for
the next four to six years and royalty
whatever right like it was sort of like
um
I was sort of going into it I didn't
have that kind of security necessarily
going into it and um
and it's it's funny because yeah people
would sort of think well
if you go and do that you you
it's funny the way it's worked out
because it's swimming coming back into
swimming has sort of
had actually almost opened up more
opportunities for me
outside of swimming
um
partially just because I think people
thought it was interesting and wanted to
be part of it um
and but but go but beginning that like I
I didn't know or think that I'd be able
to make any money through it at least
for years
um you know I just thought I'd be sort
of
staring at the black line by myself and
right have no one care about it or just
think I was nuts for at least I was
prepared for that to be the reality for
at least like
you know two to three years before
I also didn't think I'd I'd progress as
quickly as I did too so you're surprised
that I was prepared for like to be I was
prepared to be for like at least
two years before like I was
anywhere near where the willingness to
make that deal like that's what we're
interesting and this idea of being out
of alignment with like your higher
better self or this Vision or this sense
of like who you are and how you wanted
to like show up in the world being
tweaked and you know kind of upside down
while you're in Los Angeles yeah and
having enough self-awareness
conviction and courage to correct that
and now be in this place where you like
who you are you feel good about what
you're doing yeah
I think is is
something that everybody on some level
can relate to like I think that there is
um
a more self-actualized authentic version
of ourselves within all of us yeah and
every day we're you know we're kind of
subconsciously wondering how in
alignment we are with that person that
we wish we were or whatever you know
what I mean yeah
um and that never ends until we die uh
I've certainly gone through you know my
version of that and yeah I'm not perfect
in that regard but to have that kind of
awareness as a young person and to
correct that I think is
exemplary and also puts you in a
position to speak to like that subject
in general like
are we really thinking about what we're
doing like
what is Our intention and how do our
actions line up with like the
aspirational version of ourself or what
is that dormant Dream Within all of us
that maybe we're ignoring or repressing
yeah because life is hard and
we're busy and like just trying to put
food on the table is you know big enough
challenge for for most people it's it's
so easy and yeah it's so easy to get
stuck in
and I'm not saying everyone should just
go and quit their jobs and like become a
movie director or whatever but like
um it's so easy to
totally ignore it in the in the Quest
for a steady salary or you know this or
that um but when you I think you get
these little knocks yeah yeah
how are you doing in there yeah yeah
you're good remember me I'm over here
I'm still here if you want to have a
chat and it's often that it's often like
the kid in you right like the child in
you the one that that the child like
follows instincts and follows impulses
and and and and and listens to himself
um rediscovering that I think is
important
um
yeah it's something
beyond the mind and logic that is
childlike and uncorrupted by the
difficulties of life that still kind of
lives as this seedling inside of us yeah
it's a good way um
you know looking at your career in your
life the rear view is always 20 20 right
like when you look backwards it all
makes perfect sense yeah when I see your
career and the kind of art that you were
interested in in cultivating and the way
that you express yourself as an artist
the theme of swimming is like undeniable
like it's all about water you know like
subconsciously then it's like it's all
about like water in the ocean and you
know your band was called the tide like
it's all like of course of course this
guy was going to find his way back to
the pool yeah it was a self-fulfilling
prophecy kind of yeah so fulfilling
prophecy that that was yeah as you said
Team clock like
looking back on it now it all makes
sense but there was a subconscious you
know this little subconscious murmur in
there the whole time it was just drawing
me back to where I I felt most at home
or whatever
um
but
talking about that alignment with
yourself I I now feel I now truly sort
of feel that way and I think for viewers
I didn't feel that way and I and I I'm
so happy I followed it because
I
I never thought I'd be able to just sort
of sit around and say I'm really even in
the midst of grueling training and doing
all that stuff like I it satisfies me I
can sit down
in my day and go yeah I'm at PACE with
myself
and and I'm as happy as I've ever been
and and I feel like I'm on the path I'm
supposed to be on and sure it took me a
little while to to find it but
um and I think now I just have learned
things even if I stopped tomorrow and
went back to to playing music full-time
I feel like I'd be
the kind of
the kind of person I'd want to be going
back into playing music full-time I
think I'd have the right approach
and I think swimming teachers has taught
me that yeah already
yeah that's cool I think that that's
that's sort of the new cool way to be a
performer also yeah like an athlete
artist right well yeah it was like we
were talking before the podcast and I
was going about it Mike Posner like he's
sort of on a similar thing like yeah hey
man I did that other thing like you know
I took a pill in Ibiza like I know I
know that story yeah and you know I
don't want to live that way anymore and
now I want to walk across America and
climb Everest and take people on
adventures and yes I'm still cranking
out songs and my songs rule yeah
but I don't have to be that cliche of
what you think a performer's life looks
like yeah I
that's why I
admire Jack Johnson so much as well
um and why even when I was in LA I was
like why am I doing this the way Jack
does it you know he's he he or Donovan
frankenre or Donovan yeah who I've had
the chance to yeah yeah I've met him had
the chance to to play with and and chat
to and
um the guys that just forged their own
path outside like I don't know if I
don't know if Jack's been in the Grammys
uh from memory like he's never there
like and and whether that is by choice I
don't know
um but have you met him jack I've met a
couple times only briefly
um
but just watching the way he
does his thing
um
he's just I'm sure he had so many
opportunities to to go other directions
and he's always just stayed yeah on his
own
you know sure his you know he had he was
a professional Surfer and he has his an
accident that sort of redirected him
into
I suppose creative you know more
creative path which is obviously worked
out the way it has for him and for the
benefit of all of us who like his music
um
but I I just admire guys like that and
and and feel like now I have the the
sort of confidence and and self
I have the internal Compass to hopefully
keep that yeah keep that head like as
when I didn't go back so that's what a
valuable lesson to learn as a young
person like maybe you had to have those
Peak experiences to Grapple with that
and come to terms with it but to be able
to have Clarity on that at your age
creates a foundation for your success
and your happiness As you move forward
yeah yeah and and I feel so grateful for
that because I know it just as easily
could have happened when I was 45
instead of 25 and I'm just like it's
never or never yeah I'm so grateful that
it has happened now
um and maybe I'll have more of them in
the future like I might I don't know
what kind of Cycles I'll go through as I
get older and
what more I'll learn but I feel like
I've I've been able to take a lot from
my life experience so far right which is
good you re-shared uh you re-shared a
tweet the other day
um somebody had tweeted uh like hey
remember that kid cody that sang songs
like this is what he looks like now and
he's going for the Olympics and it's a
picture of you with your captain you're
like oh you're climbing out of the pool
or something like that and you're
looking super jacked and you re-shared
it and you're like yeah that's what I'm
doing I don't remember but it was sort
of like a funny thing and I I was
thinking about that because there's
probably a lot of people out there who
are fans of your music or maybe were at
a time and then haven't thought about
you and suddenly they see this and
they're like what the hell is this like
I see that on especially on Twitter I
see that because I feel like I don't
know why Twitter communities is that way
but but I'll see that on Twitter a fair
bit whereas somebody that one of one of
seen or heard from me in
since you know from a moment say eight
years ago or whatever and and they see
that I'm now doing this and they kind of
think it's
some kind of weird joke right or it's
just sort of a mind Exploder right yeah
it's so orthogonal it's a lot of people
think of you
um and I think the reason I bring that
up is I think there can be a sense in
the world publicly that all of this kind
of happened with ease or or overnight
and and without an appropriate level of
appreciation for the courage of making
that kind of decision and the amount of
work that you have to
um
put into it and uh I think what happens
is that a narrative gets crafted that
you're just you're this unbelievably
gifted person it's all easy you can just
write these songs and then and then you
can just go over to the pool and these
things happen and it makes you
unrelatable like you're this outlier
like right like that's cool and I can be
inspired by that but it's not
aspirational because I you know I'm not
I'm not like that right and I was
listening to your conversation with
Brett Hawk
and he was framing it
um in an interesting way
um to disabuse people of that idea and
to instead suggest
this idea that I love and that I believe
in which is that we all are sitting on
top of mountains of untapped potential
and the differentiator with you of
course you have talents that's certain
we all have everybody does the talents
and different things you recognize your
talents you put the work into to
manifest them but Brett said
that uh what what people should
understand is that you
understand your potential and you know
how to continually tap into that well
and go back to it it's a renewable
resource as opposed to the person who
maybe Taps into it once and does
something and says well yeah but I'm out
of gas now like that was my thing and
now and whereas you're like no it's
there it's always there like how do you
how do you dip your toe into that
current and you know continue to nourish
yourself and you know with this
understanding that uh there's always
more potential to be mined yeah yeah
yeah tapping that source so how do you
think about that consciously does that
resonate with you or yeah yeah and I
think
it's just
I think cultivating the resilience not
to get discouraged by failure as well
I think there was a there was a moment
my first
I wasn't I wasn't
as you say when you think people
think it happened overnight or whatever
like I wasn't I was no good when I first
got back in the pool you know it wasn't
like I just started popping all these
good times and training and doing all
this stuff it was like my first race
back was terrible it was absolutely
terrible and I was so afraid to do it as
well like um Brett put me in some time
trial down with David Marsh's group I've
probably only been swimming I've
probably been training for about three
months
um at that point and and certainly not
hadn't built enough to do a good 200
freestyle but he put me in the 200 free
and yeah that that that event doesn't
lie I woke up yeah I know yeah and he
you know been doing give me all the
Sprint training and doing all this but
at the time he he thought that I'd be a
200 swimmer and so he was trying to
start training me in that way and put me
in this 200 long before I was ready to
do it and I had so much anxiety about it
like I woke up the morning of and in
this like full body rash just from I've
never had any kind of physical
manifestation of stress or anxiety
before in my life
and I've got this full body rash I'm
wondering what it is I take myself to
the Urgent Care and I'm trying to figure
it out and eventually I can kind of calm
myself down and I go and do the race
that night and it's just horrible like
and I I remember
I remember coming back that night and
sort of
thinking maybe this isn't for me am I
aiming over my own head like is this you
have the that that that moment of you're
drinking your own Kool-Aid yeah yeah was
I was I Delirious in thinking that this
was possible for me but you know it's
just is this going to be too hard and
I wanted I was so frustrated that night
I think I think I'm maxed out on
push-ups at like midnight and then went
to sleep because I had all this like
pent up like frustration and anger in me
and woke up the next day not sure if I
was gonna keep going
um and then I just looked in the mirror
and thought you know what I've only
given it three months let's give it six
and then after six months if I'm still
feeling this way if I haven't
seen anything else if I haven't seen any
any Improvement or anything I think you
got to give it six to yeah and then and
then at six months
or yeah it was about two and a half
months later I got my first
um qualifying time to go and compete at
Australian Olympic trials and that was
so that was my first little win and then
it started to snowball from there I'm so
glad I saw those little two months that
two three month period through is is
part of that like that panic attack
response a function of the fact that you
know as someone who is a public figure
that whatever you do in the pool is
going to get talked about in a way that
isn't going to get talked about if you
were just an average person oh for sure
yeah I mean I wish external factors of
just who you are that make it different
yeah yeah and knowing that you know
I didn't even think about this when I
when I first when I went and did that
little USC time trial where I went 51
short course yeah I was like swims
around I did some article about it yeah
and I'm like I wish they I wish they
didn't because like I don't want that to
be there no no no not really not my
guide Mel though no no it wasn't
trashing because I think at that point
people just
I think people didn't really know that I
was
you know swimming or I wanted to sort of
a series that you would even I think I
think people just thought like oh that's
kind of interesting and it's actually
not that bad for someone that right did
you know yeah at all yeah you can jump
in and pop off a 51 like yeah good on
you like if you come if you go and see
you know
not a Justin Bieber going just do like
some random track track and field meet
and go like you know 11 for like a
hundred I know they're like this is the
thing you'd be like what the hell
whatever describing to other people like
I would talk to my wife and a couple of
I'm like yeah I'm gonna go talk to this
guy Cody you know uh and if they haven't
um heard of you or don't know who you
are I'm like just imagine it's like it's
like if Justin Bieber was also an
Olympic Athlete or Shawn Mendes or
somebody like that you know I suppose so
yeah yeah
if Sean all of a sudden was like on the
Olympic uh hockey team or something hmm
not that I've made the Olympics one of
the other things that that that you
talked about with Brett was this tall
poppy thing like this this very specific
Aussie thing where yeah we think we love
our underdogs
we want our underdogs to win but then
when they win
the relationship shifts a little bit and
it's like
don't get too big buddy yeah yeah we're
quick to cut you down and I I was with
don't win again yeah like yeah don't win
again yeah and don't win three times I
think it's heightened in Australia but
it's not unique to Australia I think
it's a no there's like there's something
human about that
um and I was I was with Ned Brockman the
other day who who you know ran across
Australia and is very famous for his
mullets yeah and what's interesting
about the mullet that he rocks is that
on the one hand it's authentically who
he is it's this kid who grew up on a
farm and Sparky was an apprentice to
become an electrician like kind of just
a bloke like like a blue collar guy and
that's who he is yeah but the other
piece of it I think is very intentional
like he he maintains it because he
understands that tall poppy phenomenon
like he wants to make sure everybody
understands who he is and that he's true
to kind of his roots yeah um yeah so
that uh people are able to kind of meet
him where he's at and and embrace him
but you coming in with everything that
happened in La I kind of grew up away
from all that yeah like I grew up away
from the tall poppy right thing like now
you're in it you're here and you're in
it yeah right like does that occupy like
you contend with that or
yes and no I think um
I definitely think that well you know
living in La like people are a little
bit more used to just people wearing
whatever and you kind of don't really
look twice if you know someone's wearing
like silver pants or something you know
what I mean but like here you'd
right at least in the culture in
Australia like you'd kind of go so
that's that's different you know I've
seen I've seen Justin Bieber so yeah
reflective like a chrome wrap like Audi
R8 or something but whereas here people
go what the hell you know what are you
doing you like her or whatever you know
but like
so yeah it's a certainly become more
become more conscious so since moving
back but I feel like I kind of
almost needed a bit of that in my life
you know over there it can it can right
yeah actually yeah it was healthy for
you it was healthy for me to have that
at that yeah at that point so and and I
think now
um
yeah I've had just enough of a dose of
it to sort of just level me out a little
bit you're still an underdog
yeah yeah which is cool which is cool
yeah I'd like to always stay the
underdog yeah yeah and trying to hold on
yeah to the top yeah so
you also happen to live with uh you
cohabitate with your girlfriend Emma who
just so happens to also be like the most
decorated Australian Olympian like yeah
she's for real
um so how has like
how has like her experience and
obviously she's you know somebody who
understands mindset the champion mindset
like how to achieve goals all of that
like what have you learned from her
experience that's allowed you to kind of
um compress your learning curve to
getting to where you want to be yeah
being I guess being with her and
spending so much time with her well we
we first met when she she was already in
the squad that I joined when I came back
so we met then and we always had a a
sort of a connection and a magnetism
to each other something we we didn't
address until
um
after her Olympic feat and when she was
she ended up being sustainable being
away for another sort of six months
after that and it wasn't until she came
back that we sort of connected and and
got together
um but it was always there from when we
first met and
um
I think I think in a
a good partner you you recognize a lot
of qualities that you yourself
I think either would like to possess or
already possess
um and I think we we sort of had that
with each other we recognized that we
had sort of similar approaches to
life and what we do and
um and at the same time I I just saw
that
I saw the way she handled everything she
she's doing and
um when we first met like she hadn't yet
done what she did last year until or in
2021 in Tokyo and
um but I could see that it was going to
happen just the way she she approached
each day and sort of since I guess being
in a relationship with her now and
living with her now I'm I'm inspired by
the way she she's probably the most
level-headed
athlete of that of that caliber that
I've ever
come across
um and
how do you account for that like how
does she maintain that uh she's
extremely one extremely extremely close
to a family
um extremely
grounded and and two I think is Never
Satisfied like it's funny when she just
to see her perspective on what she's
done like she didn't she doesn't even
know like you ask her how many Olympic
medals she's won like she probably knows
now that she's heard a lot of other
people say it but I think when she did
it she didn't really realize are you in
the house here somewhere she no they're
not here she's got a few other things
around but um even last year like she
became the the most decorated
Commonwealth athlete of all time like
not even Australian or like just of any
anyone
and then just shoot in Australia I mean
you're like it's like Michael Jordan I
think that's true that I'm pretty sure
that's the the stat
um but she finished the game and she
didn't know that you know
um she just sort of
that has this
really interesting approach to to
the sport that doesn't sort of involve
thinking about accolades or
intrinsically
yeah yeah
um and it's so calm through it all as
well
um
so I think it's hard to appreciate if
you're not Australian the way that
um you're like she's more successful now
than winning champions yeah yeah she's
more decorated now than than Ian Thorpe
and yeah that's Susie O'Neill and these
people that you know at least you grew
up yeah you know looking at as just the
the that's wild I mean I had I had
um I'm friends with Michael Clem so I
work you know you wake up and yeah yeah
I already think about that when I I look
at her butt Michael Clem shared with me
you know what it was like awesome yeah
when when that was at its peak insanity
and you know there were just like
basically like you know 10 story high
Billboards of of him and his teammates
like on on skyscraper yeah Sydney and
like it was just you know so he's not
like that anymore here it's not
um
I think at least at least the way last
gasp of that like kind of Superstar era
I think so like around Athens I thought
it was thought I enthalp and Grand
Hackett and
that that era of swimmers I think I
think it sort of was was at its peak
obviously around Sydney Olympics being
what it was in Australia and and sort of
every athlete that was successful in
Sydney Olympics was a absolute Mega star
and then I think it's that sort of
carried through to say Athens and then
beyond that Australian swimming I don't
think was as as sort of at the Forefront
of people's minds well now it's on you
buddy but yeah as a as an Australian
Patriot to bring it back you and Emma
yeah
um but I think that's changing a little
bit and has been changing the last few
years
um just with the success that they had
and that she had in in Tokyo and people
you know it's it's like in the news
again and it's in the newspapers and all
that stuff
um but yeah I can't imagine what that
was like then because those guys were
on top of the world at that point yeah
yeah
um just the idea of making manifest a
dream whether it's a creative dream an
athletic dream like any you know
anything like how do you think about uh
you know tackling difficult problems
weathering the challenges and the
setbacks that inherently come with that
and like kind of staying in the game
like to go from being like I could be at
any party in LA right now and I'm
choosing a stare at a black line like
there's a level of like discipline and
like self-regulation there that I think
is intrinsic to your success
um maybe that's
God gifted but us also I think it's
something that you can develop a
capacity for
you can develop it absolutely
um and I think I did develop it slowly I
think over a couple years like building
up the
um I suppose
confidence to to make the changes and
sacrifices I made to get back in the
pool or to change my lifestyle
um
I think that the
the work ethic side of of it for me has
always been
semi-natural
the the the capacity or willingness to
I guess quote unquote do whatever it
takes
um
and to prepare for and and and
never never like under preparing for
anything or is always doing what's
necessary
um has been something that
has come naturally to me I think do I um
yeah yeah
um either it's come naturally to me or I
was just sort of taught through my
through my youth I guess swimming and
then and then
everything else
sort of how to how to do that
um either way it's in me now uh
and I suppose yeah developing the
awareness that failure isn't
failure really failure or just
um
it's information it's information yeah
exactly it's information it's it's um
you know a bad race or a bad session or
something is just as important as a good
one
um and I think just developing the
capacity for resilience I think is
important but the only way you can do
that is by putting yourself in
uncomfortable situations or forcing
yourself to do things that you just
didn't
or don't think you can do and I think
that was part of what I think Barrett
Hawk was really good at with me in the
in the beginning was that and he talks
about it now is that for the first six
months he just he said he was just
trying to break me all the time I
remember
it was probably only about
because if he could break you he could
save time and you'll just go back to
being in a position exactly hard press
him now just get this out of the way
yeah and and he he said he tried and
tried so many times and I'd I'd get out
and throw up and then get back in just
like we had so many moments that early
on where I had no sort of aerobic
fitness or capacity for lactate or any
of that you hadn't been a swimmer long
enough to develop that base that you
know so the stuff that he was trying to
make me do at that time would just make
me vomit and that was probably two three
times a week for a while until I was a
little fitter
um
I remember one morning like I'd I'd just
broken up with my girlfriend the night
before
um
and I come in the next day I'm I'm you
know down and
and whatever and he he goes okay 200 fly
time trial it's like what the you
know
and he goes what if you break up with
your girlfriend not before the Olympics
in four years you got to be able to get
up and you know do this and it's just
little things like that that
um getting so far out of your comfort
zone that you you
just feel like you're off in the deep
end you know and then you start to find
your feet yeah it creates resilience
within you and and um
so I think that's just something I've
been slowly
developing those building blocks of
resilience sort of since I started
swimming again
um
I yeah sometimes you just sort of just
have to jump off the deep end and then
find your feet once you're out there
um
you're never going to be ready
that's that's what I've realized you're
never going to be ready or think you're
never going to feel already sorry you
might so you might as well train to do
it when you're not ready yeah yeah if
the stars align and you are ready great
but you know how to do it when
everything's not yeah the way you wish
it would be yeah exactly and just you
just start doing things and and
you know that you know that the first
time you do it you know for example say
a 2005 and he actually he actually made
me do one the very first day he got to
LA to train me
and like it was it was horrible you know
it was it was the most painful thing
ever
um
he goes okay yeah oh mate that could
hardly finish it and he goes okay well
we've got that out of the way like
that's the worst it's ever gonna feel
and I was like okay well that was
horrible but it wasn't
my life's not over like it wasn't that
bad you know right yeah well if that's
the worst it's ever gonna feel that's
okay you know it's just finding figuring
out those unknowns
developing the mental toolkits like if
you're oh then now I have something to
build on like it's just a different lens
to like look at where you're at yeah and
get it and doing something rather than
doing something for the first time no
matter how bad it is right whether it's
writing your first song or writing your
first screenplay or or
your first day at a new job or something
just do it no matter how it is you
know and the next one will be better and
then so on
and before you know it it's almost like
that compound interest Theory or that
lack theory that you know
uh
what's that theory if you double
something
every time you doubles compounded yeah
yeah
you're building it with these little
microphones and then you get to yeah
it's invisible and it's Anonymous until
one to eight isn't yeah yeah I love that
are you writing so like you must be too
tired to be writing songs and well now
you're in taper maybe you got a little
more energy it's so funny that my
having experienced the way like my
creative
my creative side or impulses are so
dampened by my exhaustion the training
like
I'll take a break from training we might
get two weeks off for the year or
something and then like a couple days
into that two weeks all of a sudden I'm
just having all these crazy ideas and
all this and I'm like why isn't it
always like this and always and then I
remember how tired I am usually all the
time
um because you're swimming 20 000 meters
a day or whatever it is but I'm still
um I'm still riding yeah I'm still
playing
not not as much as I would be otherwise
but yeah I try not to sort of
let that let that fade to too much I'm
still sort of compiling ideas and songs
and things that I can come back to when
I have the time yeah yeah
and I will I will eventually
be starting to
play and make music again yeah I'm
looking forward to the day I'm not
worried about that yeah I have no doubt
you know that will come when it's
supposed to come but in the meantime
dude like honor to talk to you I'm a fan
um super supportive of this mission that
you're on I think it takes a lot of
courage to you know kind of make the
moves that you that you have and I think
there's so much to be learned by the
example that you're setting and I feel
like you're you're showing up in a way
that
um
is setting a really positive example for
other people and how they kind of think
about their own dreams in their own life
so thank you yeah thank you credit to
you and um we didn't talk about Prince
Neptune you're an entrepreneur garment
line and also there's a isn't there a
documentary out there kind of
chronicling your swim ideas all came
together so quickly that I wasn't able
to like see that or yeah no this that
was um
that's cool having that because that
documents the early the very early days
of of me getting back into it it was a
documentary following it's on Prime
video
um documenting or following four
different Australian swimmers um at
different stages in their career
um Ian thought was one of them
um
and uh so I was I was in that and they
were sort of documenting the early
stages of me
making the transition and coming in and
um and so that's out there yeah cool
yeah all right well we'll link that up
in the shout outs your Cody Simpson
okay cool
um right on man you're gonna play a song
thanks come on
um if I can have a second
figure something out
[Music]
young lady lover on the top of the world
can't put my trust in all the things
that I've heard foreign
[Music]
how's it gonna be
how's it going to be
[Music]
when you don't know me
I used to run inside that Circle you win
that little bubbles bound to burst in a
bit
going with goodbye to
[Music]
me no can you feel me letting go
how's it going to be
foreign
[Music]
oh
curse you can
I can't stand the things you're happy
you found but I feel
I feel I'll be cool at last
cause this is how it's gonna be
you don't know me do you thank you
how's it going to be
[Music]
no
okay
[Applause]
thank you